let's say you need to borrow some money
from in particular you are going to
borrow one hundred dollars for years so
that's you and this is me and there's I
give you two options so option number
one is I just lend you one hundred
dollars I just lend you one hundred
dollars and then one year goes by and
then after the year you would owe me one
hundred dollars plus some interest one
hundred dollars plus some interest so
that's option number one now option
number two is a little bit interesting
option number two let me write this
option does in a different color option
option number 2 i'm going to lend you a
hundred dollars so i'm going to lend you
one hundred dollars but instead of a
year going by i'm going to say that one
week goes by one week goes by and you're
going to owe me the hundred dollars the
hundred dollars plus some plus some
interest and you say wait wait hold on i
needed to borrow a hundred dollars for a
year this doesn't work out I over here
you're only giving it for a week and I
say okay look relax you'll owe me the
hundred dollars plus interest in a week
but so that you don't have to have that
money right then and there I'm going to
give you another loan I'm going to give
you a loan for that hundred dollars plus
interest I'm going to give you a loan
for that hundred dollars hundred dollars
plus interest for the week so that you
could use that money to pay me back for
the first loan and then you're going to
owe me the hundred dollars plus interest
plus interest on that in another week in
another week so now you're going to have
a hundred dollars one hundred dollars
plus some interest plus sup interest
plus even more interest I'm obviously
not being particularly exact but you
could see you now have interest on the
interest even more interest and the
second plan that I give you we
essentially just continue this process
after every week if you want to continue
another loan and I'm going to continue
to do this for a year so this process
this process is going to continue going
on for an entire
year and at the end of that year you
finally I don't know what you did you
had some type of investment or some type
of a business and you finally pay me
back without taking out another loan a
hundred dollars one hundred dollars plus
all accumulated interest all all the
interest that has accumulated now the
question I have for you is from my point
of view where would I want to charge
more interest so here I've charged you a
year has gone by and you're going to pay
me back a hundred dollars plus all of
the interest over a year and then in
this scenario you're going to pick a
year is going to pass by although it
seems a little bit more complex and then
at the end of the year you were in a pat
pay me a hundred dollars plus all of the
accumulated interest over a year so the
question is which of these which of
these should be a higher number and to
answer that question we just have to
think about in which scenario am I am I
the lender taking on more risk more in
which situation am I taking on more risk
in scenario one a lot could happen in
that year something might bad might
happen through your investment might go
bad the value of the dollar might go
down you might have a hyperinflationary
environment in this scenario right here
if anything shady were to happen at any
point in time I could cut you off I'm
not guaranteeing you that I'm going to
chart i'm going to give you another loan
i'm just kind of saying look if you're
still good for it if you're still around
if your business still looks good i'm
going to give you another loan if
anything shady happens i'm going to
demand my money and I'm not going to
give you another loan the other thing
that I have the option of doing in
scenario two is adjusting the interest I
only have to set the interest for the
next week and then the week after that
and then the week after that I can maybe
if let's say we're an inflationary
environment or let's say the cost of
money is going up money is getting
scarce then I can charge even more
interest so viewed that way viewed that
way in scenario one where I don't see
any money and I don't have any chance to
kind of cut you off after a week or two
weeks or three weeks this is much more
this is more
and this right over here is less risk
and so given that when I lend you money
for a year in this context i am going to
charge you a higher interest let me
change colors higher higher interest in
the situation that I'm taking on more
risk here assuming that you kept being
good for and I kept Lin felt I keep
feeling like lending you money week
after week after week I took on less
risk because I could have cut you off at
any point so here it would be rational
for me to charge you lower interest
lower interest lower interest for lower
risk